promu l'an dernier jour à cannes lors de
la soirée de gala la palme d'or décernée
à michael moore sera projeté à nouveau
une récompense qui fait couler beaucoup
d'encre le jury du festival de cannes a
expliqué ses choix en plébiscitant le
réquisitoire anti bush de michael moore
premier documentaire depuis 1956 à
recevoir la plus haute distinction
le jury donc s'est défendu de toute
arrière-pensée politique parce qu'elle
défend hervé poteau pour la première
fois de son histoire le festival avait
prévu de confronter le jury à la presse
après le palmarès et ça ne pouvait pas
mieux tomber
c'est donc à guichet fermé que tarantino
et ses jurés se sont expliqués si le
film avait été mauvais même s'il avait
exprimé mes idées politiques je ne leur
ai pas défendu je répète que ma priorité
ce n'est pas la politique c'est le
cinéma quand le gros politique cohabite
avec du grand cinéma
voilà voilà quand je vais voir un film
c'est parce que j'ai envie de ressentir
des choses ça peut être alors et le rire
les pleurs ça peut être aussi la prise
de conscience de quelque chose et c'est
pour moi tout ce qui fait le cinéma et
c'est réellement ce que j'ai ressenti en
voyant le film aqueux mort moi ça ne me
gêne pas du tout cas réalisateur mais
qu'un seul point de vue les gens ne sont
pas dû vous pouvez regarder le film sur
de michael moore et puis vous allez voir
autre chose les gens ne sont pas dupes
et pour les jurés moore a su défendre ce
point de vue avec l'art d'un grand la
projection de son film lundi avait
d'ailleurs emballer les festivaliers
2000 spectateurs l'avaient ovationné
pendant 20 minutes
parfois arrive un livre un film un
morceau de musique qui touche les gens
échangent leur vision du monde
sinon vous me demandez comment bush va
réagir à ma palme d'or mais il ne sait
même pas ce que c'est j'espère qu'on ne
lui apprendra pas la nouvelle pendant
qu'ils mangent un bretzel
en tout cas cette pâle me restera dans
les mémoires comme un pied-de-nez lancé
à tous les puissants par deux sales
mômes deux cinéastes imprévisible issue
de cette amérique qu'on dit profonde une
palme d'or qui devrait sortir aux états
unis le 2 juillet